[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon chéri merci panthères j'adore eh
bien tu arrives à la ferme célébrités
alors on a quoi aujourd'hui mon bébé
alors depuis la rentrée sur france 2
c'est le tour de france est coriace du
cyclisme à la vélos et cyclistes
à la télé on se pose tous et même
question est ce que les gars sont non
combien parce que quand on est pas celui
qu'ils se posaient des questions sur du
vélo tu vois même des journalistes
sportifs qui galèrent deux parties vous
allez nous préciser une chose
intéressante
est ce plus facile de rouler
tranquillement ou de rouler à bloc
ah ça c'est une question ça c'est une
question qu'on n'en sait ça c'est une
question pour ça c'est une vraie
question
vous aimez les belles voix vous êtes
professionnel de la musique vous
cherchez à des chine a déniché la pépite
qui va caracolé en tête des charts et
bien passez votre chemin ce qui arrive
tout de suite ça va pas du tout pour
vous
on va s'aimer on va sens bien c'est au
mariage de fanny et mathieu allons
enfants de la paix tant que le jour de
gloire est
est arrivé en pente avec nous nos boules
de pétanque un petit rond point ton que
ce beau sport arrive aux jo je promets
le ciel au baiser de ta bouche je te
promets le miel à ma main qui te tue sa
magnifique la pic atteint pendant la
dernière recrue du diabète communiqué
quand c'est ça c'est la dernière recrue
du jamel comedy club qui cartonne tous
les jours dans télématin attention
faites du bruit du bruit du bruit
[Applaudissements]
avec des places bien nous passer les
cheminots ne sont projetés dans le
respect des mesures anti qu'ovide et
voilà pour les jt je retrouve dans une
heure or et c'est bien pour la france
une bonne nouvelle ça aurait pu tomber à
l'eau venise est tombé à l'eau par
contre cette date plus jamais encore
comme sera pas durer dix jours 1 et
voilà pour l'info je me retrouve à 8h30
avec ce festival qui aurait pu tomber à
l'eau il a refermé lors du talent du
jour aujourd'hui le talent c'est fini
elle est vice-championne des yvelines du
rire de merde
le talent de jours il a beaucoup de
talent tu seras pas et maintenant on
mange équilibré aider les couples à oyem
bien fait rire dans la quotidienne sur
france 5 un petit chien tout mignon est
sur le plateau et ce petit chien tout
mignon il lâche une petite caisse tout
comme on est sur france 5 et ben on
reste classe tranquille qui arrive en
tête et que des synergies positives donc
là bas c'est bien ça fait plaisir en
france en france 10% des hommes ne
change de slip ou de caleçons qu'une
seule fois par semaine c'est dans
l'actualité récemment
est ce que le chiffre et exactions nous
envoie du bonheur
alors là
attendez deux secondes ce serait ce
petit chien tout mignon pour l'accusé
non parce que s'il faut retrouver le
vrai coupable
moi j'ai ma petite idée alors là moi je
m'en fais l'avocat des chiens pour se
défendre des lourdeurs et ce matin
j'étais tranquille ou dans la voiture
quoi ça tranquille tranquille vous dans
ma voiture et qui j'entends pas sur
skyrock la personne à celui d'ivoire où
le d'amour or avec moi le 23 septembre
ça fait 18 ans ne l'a pas affecté ok
c'est à dire que en ce moment tous les
jours vous êtes à skyrock c'est ça dont
je suis venu comme ça on potes si vous
avez loupé ce matin regarder ce que ça
donnait web alors ça va ma chérie avec
toi je te remets pas mon bébé
jamais eh bien tu as vu l'article toi tu
n'avoues pas et le gars tu l'as vu au
pays
non rires parce que tu as vu le gars qui
t'attend dit à la sortie
salut tu l'as vu mon nom ma faute à
l'eau et à l'eau et ma faute
quelle est la seule radio qui te permet
de gagner 1500 euros tous les matins ah
oui oui bonjour c'est qui
mahfoud j'écoute quelle radio tous les
jours les émissions que c'est toujours
la dark avec ta bonne c'est toujours
chaleur et je vends de l'école on me
procès il est le numéro 1 la télé alou
leur pécule celada retard et toi mon
hanouna
non on va l'inviter j'ai jamais fait
exactement et je vais l'inviter chez
pearson numéro 73 réunions mais c'est
énorme
grâce à ce numéro de panique j'avais pas
venez je te jure je tenais je n'avais
jamais rencontré
ça va pousser les tu veux nous faire un
petit à petit truc quand derek lam asie
séries c'est quoi que j'avais prévu de
3,3 millions galaga la voûte chéri bien
là va dit attends tu regrettes hommes
évasif il le fait je vous faisais l'asie
légèrement plus d'ambiance que ça et je
voulais te remercier parce que ça m'a
grave touche et mieux mais vraiment je
te jure j'étais hyper ému de chansons et
voilà je voulais dire merci je voulais
nous faire ça la chanson tout de suite
tu nous l'as far en direct la allez
vas-y vas-y mettez la recrue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas
ça va démarrer avec nous
nous la farce en musique
un habitant
le comfort 1 de l'école on me pose et il
est la numéro 1 à la télé à la fin de
l'es4 montauzer lui mais là
numéro 1 à la télé ana al oumma c'est la
dalle comment allouer à toute l'algérie
sur ses métiers à l'ina avec la cedar
camorra lima
[Musique]
un cadeau dont est ce que peut-on faire
une console de jeux ok c'est une console
de jeu ou pas tu en as ou pas déjà en
attendant veut pas imminente une
nouvelle te prends pas la tête je la
prendrai merci mon chéri d'amour